herzlich kommen zu einer neuen folge ich
fahre leute wir sind heute auf einem
parkhaus berg in köln wir sehen da
hinten den kölner dom leute und heute
ist der tag wo ich nachdem ich jetzt
schon drei autos von anderen usern
bewertet habe euch auch mal zeigen
welchen wagen ich fahrer bzw welchen
wagen mein bruder max wert der heute
nehmen wir ist halo sgv leute heute ist
es mein auto zumindest im titel wir sind
was viele bestimmt nicht wissen quasi
nachbarn und deshalb teilen wir uns
einfach ein auto weil wir leben mitten
in der großstadt haben festgestellt wir
fahren eigentlich beide nie gleichzeitig
genau und deshalb ist das unser
gemeinsames auto und wir zeigen euch
heute mercedes 450
[Applaus]
mercedes-benz sechszylinder
[Musik]
überlegen
sicher
[Musik]
klinger
hier können wir zeigen als allererstes
nein so ist es ja hier
das war nämlich zu machen wir gern
direkt
wir haben hier 19 zoll felgen drauf sind
noch die winter 1990 verkehrt machen wir
sind noch die die winterreifen im sommer
auf zwang ist guck mal hier
das geile einem e coupé leute ich mache
sich immer auch hier übrigens fußboden
und so ist sie doch ein bisschen dirty
aber von außen abgewaschen wie dieses
gesagt hat b-säule york bruder einfach
die macht das hat schon mit sky oder mit
einer der geilsten sachen am e coupé
einfach keine b soll hier komplette
komplette durchreiche ansonsten muss man
sagen ja es leute die kenner wir haben
leider kein schiebedach drehen würde man
eigentlich c frei nehmen bei der
konfiguration wir hatten den wagen aber
als fertigen wagen so bestellt heißt wir
konnten nichts mehr verändern ein paar
sachen sind nicht so wie man sie
eigentlich machen würde aber ja schon
mal hintenrum e-450 von matic 450 heißt
wir haben einen sechszylinder-benziner
der informatik heirat antriebsachse mal
rein auf die fußballerischen fußmatten
guck dir einfach mal nicht hin aber hier
ist das für mich wichtigste einem
gesamten autor er hat mbx jetzt hier das
uns also seht ihr hier dran an dem den
kleist hat den sprachassistenten der
funktioniert ungefähr so hell mercedes
navigieren nach amsterdam
soll ich die zielführung starken ja okay
so
guck mal hier wir haben richtig geil die
burmester anlage in schwarzer esche ist
gut man sieht es jetzt klappt nicht
genannt
du kannst aus halt die frage ist auf
jeden fall nicht richtig geilen geilen
kleinholz esche schwarz nennt sich
nennen sich diese diese einsätze hier
die sind auch richtig cool hier das will
ich auch richtig geil weil der e klasse
in der mitte der angeklagte ist ja auch
eine werbeplattform diese luftauslässe
richtig sexy genug des covers lassen uns
fahren wir lieber die erste frage bei
diesem format ist immer was bedeuten
autos für dich gar nicht so leicht zu
beantworten ich glaube da hat sich aber
auch noch niemand so gleich getan
ja ja ja ja das war immer eine relativ
lange erklärung eigentlich also nicht
mag autos ich bin ein bisschen weniger
auto begeistert als du jetzt auf jeden
fall aber ich gucke auf jeden fall auch
gerne so ich setzte mich auch aktiv
damit auseinander also zb fußball wird
er hätte nicht wirklich gar nicht so
eigentlich wobei fairerweise ich gucke
auch manchmal so besonnen praktikanten
videos also ich schaute da so ein
praktikant wirklich zehn jahren oder so
das tue ich schon gerne aber ich bin
trotzdem noch ein bisschen mehr
involvierten das auto thema aber autos
bedeuten für mich eigentlich luxus okay
weil ich interessiere mich nur für die
jeder ich interessiere mich eigentlich
vor allem für für neiße autos und das
bringt dann immer luxus mit sich so also
die mobilität ist ein krasser luxus wenn
du eine karat mit der du immer rum
fahren kannst damit meine ich nicht dass
ich das für mich das gleiche auto
rolls-royce ist aber das ist immer
luxusbauten zu feiern
für dich ja das ist eigentlich so die
kurzform ich habe ich ja gerade schon
angeschnitten ich liebe technik
technologisch fortgeschrittene autos
infotainment ist mir sehr wichtig ich
habe aber auch spaß daran schnell zu
fahren so also ich bin auch flott auf
der autobahn hatte feststellen als ich
also leute ich habe einige von einem
kommentare unter den videos gesehen
sowohl der übertreibt aber wissen sowie
der gas gibt ich war wirklich nicht mehr
mag auch gesagt habt sehr sehr gespannt
auf entspannt auf der autobahn so 130
140 150 max du willst du bist ja so der
historiker testen so gut es geht also
eher klar ist ja in dem format auch mal
nah am gaspedal leute deswegen lehnt
euch daran kein vorbild fahrt immer
sicher wie möglich und genau das kann ja
wohl dazu noch sagen aber ich habe auf
jeden fall auch mal spaß an das macht so
eine eintönige autofahrt ein bisschen
abwechslungsreicher wenn man auch mal
kleider es gibt so gerade mit dem amg
hatte ich das auf jeden fall
herrschten nach 10 43 angela von maximal
vierter das war wirklich ein
er wurde an der wurde gut gedreht wurde
wurde gut getreten
wie schnell konnte man mit dem fahren
jetzt ja abgeregelte 250 abgesagt 50
jahre übrigens leute ganz wichtig vor
dem auto hier einige fahre ich mehr
fakten wollten bei dem porsche 911 video
von maribor hatte komplett recht wir
sitzen hier in einem design
sechszylinder benziner im besitzen im
motor mit modernen motoren nicht auf den
im auto oder soja also 610 wir beziehen
da 367 ps 500 newtonmeter und wirklich
die kombination e klasse so bisschen
schiffe klang und aber dieses ganzen
neue mbx infotainment wo mercedes
wirklich no product placement dekra aber
einfach rasiert basiert aber okay alles
klappt sind sport lustiger weil 307 cc
es ist zwar schwer schmecken finde ich
aber da geht schon was sie mir auf jeden
fall gehen da geht also zog ich vermisse
aber gar nicht so krass den c 43 ja da
natürlich der war zu dicke brett ich
also wir sind echt gefahrene relativ
viel mit dem auto okay vom beifahrersitz
ist schon geil ein bisschen auch nicht
der war zu laut so viel erwachsener das
auto das e coupé hier und auf 10 340
limo hatten wir rund ein prozent gut aus
aber das auto ist so viel erwachsener
mbx das neue lassen ist ja die große
frage du hast ja quasi den diese von
dort zu dem auto schon meine also klar
da war nicht das drin aber trotzdem 400d
genau ich hatte das vorgängermodell 400
de also 340 ps
jetzt schüler bekam der soundkarte
erdiger jetzt ist wieder der immer noch
nicht warm gefahren den ab
ich bin jetzt sozusagen also ich fahre
das auto jedoch nie in sport plus der
sache auf jeden fall auch nicht zu
schnell und slc 43 jetzt gerade ich
immer mit dem jagen
[Musik]
warum freistil noch nie sport
losgefahren ganze ich weiß nicht ob sich
immer wenn wenn so fernen zeit auf der
autobahn ist wenn man so lange strecke
deshalb ist wirklich für mich glaub ich
das größte argument gegen ein
allgemeines tempolimit dass man dadurch
so viel aktiveres fahren komplettiert
und so und einfach sich selbst ein
bisschen mehr fordert und nicht so
passiv würden also ich bin ja auch schon
viel in italien gefahren österreich
schweiz holland up and money pence ein
wer jetzt den tacho einmal und dann geht
es im halbschlaf das ist ein riesenthema
ich muss für mich klar sagen ich bin
gegen allgemeines tempolimit aber ja das
ist nun leider geschichte mathematik
sind dann nur eine oder andere hätte
sich vorstellen können
die partie übrigens auch mehr außerorts
leute ihr seht ich nenne nur euer
feedback auf jetzt was ich noch sagen
wollte wir spielen immer so ein spiel
welches auto bin ich oder welches auto
passt zu mir somit mit freundin
überlegen wie das ok was passt wie so ne
was ist was ist und ich hab letztens
mein optimal setup wenn man sich zwei
autos aussuchen dürfte also will das
team war ich mit auto genauso komplett
ohne hand und fuß einfach drauflos ohne
budget vor allem auch ohne budget auch
für unterhalt und es wäre der erst sechs
performance der es mir angetan er ist
extrem 1 und dazu ein ferrari f40 meine
wahl also wenn man zwei wunschautos ohne
budget haben kann ja jetzt so koenigsegg
oder sowas habe ich jetzt nicht mit
reingenommen weil es ja vollkommen ab sp
ist meine wahl war und hat mal eure
waren die kommentare welche zwei autos
wenn ihr kein budget hätte also open and
budget würdet ihr nehmen meine wahl wäre
rolls royce kann vielleicht sogar black
cats höher als komfortables auto mit
viel platz und dazu im porsche carrera
gt
achso leuten wirklich mal
ich möchte einen kleinen appell ich
meinen kleinen apple staaten wirklich
leute ich bin jetzt sogar ich war auch
involviert in die produktion der
bisherigen wie ich finde das ist so ein
geiles format auch wenn ihr das gerne
guckt abonniert jetzt diesen kanal die
600.000 abos den wirklich und teilt
diese videos die machen immer mega viel
schwarz produzieren sind aber auch sehr
aufwendig traber und ich finde wirklich
gut dass du damit jetzt einen frischen
wind auf deinen channel und auch auf
youtube deutschland bringt weil das ist
schon neu alle sind auch richtig dankbar
dafür dass das jetzt wieder unterstützen
jetzt anläuft und leute ich kann nur
soviel sagen wir haben gäste schon
zugesichert die sind so krank ja es
werden uns so krank er autos auf diesem
kanal die bgs wird premieren geben er
abermals man mit neckars porsche dabei
auch zum ersten mal zu sehen
aber wie ich es kommen sachen auf euch
zu in diesem format die werden sehr
krass wir werden auch sehr viel
aufmerksamkeit kriegen glaube ich hoffe
ich deshalb merkt euch die abo-zahl dann
könnt ihr immer schreiben ich war schon
beim wechsel kann man gerne machen alles
klar lasst uns mal weg sagt ich mache
das glaub ich jetzt so leute ich fahre
dieses auto wirklich so als hätte ich
noch nie drin gesessen ich im ries hätte
mich jetzt mental ja das geht wenn man
aktiv macht und ja also hier schwarzer
dachhimmel geil holz eiche schwarz die
leisten geil hier es ist das hier wenn
man das hier schließt marshall hat man
aber niemals verlieren dass man muss das
aber machen guck mal so sieht's aus wie
mein linker 10er willst und so geil o
ich habe allerdings grün
sorry ich mir okay ich lerne dieses auto
neu kennen wirklich details schön
lenkrad geil ich kann aber so viel sagen
dass wir bis von hinten sieht eine sache
die bei diesem auto nicht so gut
geworden ist sind ist die bedienung von
der lautstärke hier und vom tempomat dar
warum müssen das touch felder sein
mercedes war um bei den vorherigen
lenkrad von bild ein
hatte man so geile kippschalter hier
warum touch
es macht keinen sinn wenn ich auf der
autobahn bin und ich will keine ahnung
sagen ich bin bei 75 und will auf 100
hoch stellen
da muss ich zwei mal drücken eine feste
taste drücken für 10 km h mehr und dann
noch fünf mal hoch vision wenn es den
besseren weg gibt schreibt mir ein
aber so wie wir das ding jetzt verstehen
gerade ist es einfach ich weiß nicht ob
die leute das gerade nachvollziehen
können das ist auf jeden fall meckern
auf höchstem niveau a ja so komisch weil
es ist ein rückschritt alles ist geiler
geworden ja aber das ist ein bisschen
ein bisschen nervig geworden also in der
baumart und lautstärke ist viel dünner
geworden als beim vorherigen okay da man
hier mal wenn wir mal
eco hat man ja sport plus rein in die
luzie ja nur 30
auf dem beifahrersitz klicks mehr so
sagt ja okay also auf jeden fall sehr
komfortable ja sehr komfortabel und ich
muss sagen ich finde es auch geil bei
diesem auto es ist komfortabel klasse
muss ja auch komfortabel sein sonst
macht es keinen sinn ihn kaiser zu
nehmen aber ich hatte davor wie gesagt
den vorgänger als 400 de coupe mit
luftfahrwerk und das war so unfassbar
entkoppelt also doch ein bisschen
wirklich 200 gefahrenen hast das gefühl
die siege auf einem schaukelstuhl in der
wellnessoase und das war einfach du hast
nichts mehr gespürt ja klar irgendwo
machten luftfahrwerk das auch aber das
gefällt mir auf jeden fall besser ihre
würden für dich auch andere
autohersteller in frage kommen oder
liebste mercedes krass komplett ich bin
absolut ich bin kein marken fetischist
wir sind hier aufgewachsen mit audi
unser der hat unser onkel waren immer
mit audis unterwegs ja also ich bin
eigentlich eher noch audi kind als
mercedes ich will nie richtig übrigens
auch ja wie du auch stimmen stimmte sind
videos reden die gerne neue sachen
vertrieb ex moment so also wir sind
eigentlich auch die kinder aber mercedes
finde ich wirklich schön hat auf jeden
fall seine stärken als marke bin aber
ich mag auch bmw viele leute lieben ihr
bmw und dann gibt es viele die bmw nicht
lieben die hassen dann können wir aber
auch oft und auch bmw fahrer glaube ich
hab gar keinen stress so ich würde
niemals jemanden wissen weil die nahrung
weil ich mir jetzt mit mercedes fahren
bmw so gar keinen sinn komplett frei
leute ich habe alles gecheckt man kann
erst mal kurz anhalten so und jetzt red
i
wer geht schon voran wer geht schon
voran
er schmeckt ja 5,6 sekunden macht macht
er glaube ich auf 100 werksangabe ist
für sohn für so ein wesen das cruiser
schon sehr in spanien feiere ich finde
er ist aber auch schön so muss man auch
sagen wenn da die zwar nicht erst mal
drauf sind der er an dann geht es runter
wird rasiert
man muss es auch an der stelle mal sagen
ich bin richtig dankbar dieses auto
fahren zu dürfen richtig dankbar eine
sache leute das ist als außenstehender
nicht zur nachvollziehbar aber also in
dieser youtube fällt ihr habt ja gesehen
was sie für autos fahren die jungs nicht
turbo s gts und haben jede hat sich das
verdient jeder hat das hätte das gar
nicht schlimm aber man kann so schnell
den maßstab verlieren
100pro und das finde ich wichtig bin das
ist ein krankes auto und ich bin
unfassbar dankbar das fahren zu dürfen
ja es wirklich das ist wirklich krass
also maßstäbe verschieben sich so kraft
der hat bock und wisst ihr noch bock hat
leute ich und zwar auf die bewertung
kommen wir zum aussehen das e coupé ist
ein schönes auto das kann man denke ich
auch sagen ohne dass man mir vorwerfen
wird dass ich es bevorzuge weiß mein
eigenes ist es liegt aber zum beispiel
ganz klar für mich von der optik her
hinter dem porsche von marc gebauer und
deswegen gebe ich hier 7 von 10 punkten
die beschleunigung ist stark ich hab mal
nachgeschaut das sind tatsächlich fünf
sekunden glatt und in 5,6 sekunden von 0
auf 100 und da muss man schon relativ
hohen wert geben natürlich nicht auf dem
niveau wie zb mark i mouse branche aber
sieben von zehn sind auch in der
kategorie angebracht denke ich in puncto
cool ist sich das auto auf einem niveau
mit dames tesla ist zwar von der
technologie herr nicht ganz so
revolutionär wissen testen zum beispiel
ist hat aber dafür noch ein bisschen
stärkere marke und sieht einfach auch
schon richtig flott aus auch hier 7 von
10 punkten bei der praktikabilität kann
die ehcler vergleich zu den beiden
porsche ich die schon im format waren
natürlich punkt man kann sehr gut zu
führt da auch in langen strecken fahren
der kofferraum ist ordentlich verbrauch
hält sich relativ in grenzen sieben von
zehn die bewertung des preis
leistungsverhältnisses ist wie immer
hier natürlich auch schwierig das auto
kostet so wie es dasteht ca 93.000 euro
das ist natürlich eine gigantische summe
allerdings bekommt man ein sehr modernes
sehr komfortables und sehr ausgefeilt
das auto trotzdem und gerade deswegen
weil es ein luxusprodukt das kann ich
hier nicht höher als sechs von zehn
gehen was den komfort angeht ist das
auto ganz klar das beste unter den
bisherigen vier autos 8 von 10 punkten
finde ich hier angemessen super
geräusche situation super fahrer geile
sitze
acht von zehn einfach da bekommen wir
insgesamt auf 42 von 60 punkten genauso
viel wie lukas porsche und einige frage
ich wenn sie jetzt denken der gavotte
fa-cup glaubt mir ich würde lieber turbo
s als e klasse vorhanden das ist klar
aber wir haben eben auch alltags
kategorien dabei die preis leistung
komfort und da kann das auto eben ein
bisschen mehr punkt ich bin jetzt schon
sehr gespannt auf die nächste folge
nächsten sonntag heute bis dahin
abonniert den kanal und macht's gut